check this out dude like i think you
told me ahead of time that you are going
to do
a youtube video with a guy who's got
like a
an rv channel or like a camper van
youtube channel and
that channel i don't know what it is now
it had
15 000 subscribers
yeah and then you do this video where
you gave a tour of the van that you were
living in legitimately living in it
and it's like it's almost five million
views
yes and i've had people come up to me
and be like dude
we man's living in a van and then
because especially because i had a van
so i was just like oh
um how long were you living in the van i
lived in it for one year
i actually got two during the time
period that i lived in it
so the first one when i went to go get
one when i realized i wanted to live in
a van
uh they're like well it was back in uh
september of 2018 and they're like well
we can't build you and have it done
until
july of next year and i'm like dude i
just sold my house and i'm kind of stuck
and i was living in a hotel for like two
months
and so they're like well look on our
website and see if someone's selling one
used and this was a thursday afternoon
and i look on their website i'm like oh
that one's pretty rad let me call the
dudes i called the dude
and i go hey have you had any bites on
your band you'd go well go one guy but
he doesn't like come back
and i'm like well i'm going to be there
monday he's in arkansas
i'm going to fly in monday i'm going to
take you to lunch and i want to see your
van in person he goes all right
sounds good i'm like well don't sell it
because i'm interested
and he goes okay it sounds good he had
no clue who i was
that's how to get a shitty deal 101
right it that's how to get a shitty deal
101.
what do you mean don't sell it i'm
interested you know like not like
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you want to
have like a poker face
he added on five grand the price just
off that comment
but then he had like a bro boner once i
got there and he realized who i was
right and then then they tacked on
another attack
the boner tax dude
so um i think he said something really
interesting that you know you said that
uh
i sold my house and now i'm kind of
stuck
um i mean that's like you
cut it sounded to me like you were like
dude i sold my house i'm moving to
canada
i'm gonna live on a farm that's what was
first gonna happen and then the plan
fell through
after you sold the house yes exactly
what happened
and so you're like okay so i'm not
moving to canada anymore i changed my
mind
and i already sold my house so now is
that why you decided that you wanted to
live in a van
yeah because in 2018 the
the real estate market was kind of high
and i knew i didn't want to buy in la
again
and i wanted to do something bigger so i
was like [ __ ] what am i gonna do
so i just started researching bands and
i got stoked on the mercedes sprinter
one so i started
checking them out checking them out and
i actually called my buddy who i knew
wrapped him and did different things and
i'm like what do you know about these i
need more info
and when i texted him he actually sent
me a photo he was driving his he's like
come by in the morning
i'll tell you all about them yeah so
yeah
i did my whole research before i went
and got one
now when you were living in the van for
that whole year like where would you
typically most often sleep
like where would where would you park it
mainly like campsites that like rvs
would camp at
uh-huh yeah i was kind of sketched i did
a couple like i did quite a few times
like they would say walmart parking lots
yeah and then like i did flying j gas
stations
because in the morning you can go in and
take a full shower and all that
and get whatever you need so i did those
a few times
and then after a while i just i kind of
got tired of
wondering where i was i had a toilet in
my van
and i just hated taking a [ __ ] in it and
then having to clean it out you know
so funny i love the luxury of having
that
but i hated the cleaning part of it
we've
with with this one we've got a toilet
right here
uh we piss in it but we don't shouldn't
it
yeah it's a compromise yeah no no i i
would do that all the time like i didn't
care about that
yeah every morning you know how you wake
up every morning you got to drop in
goose
i know i know you do you're the most
regular guy i know
i got hey like you and you drink your
coffee and then that makes you [ __ ]
every time
every morning that's not like you you
don't do that no
i do that every morning well i don't
know you as well as i know him
hey do you have any did you ever have
any crazy experiences like sleeping over
at night some of these places
in like the middle of america like
people knocking on your door [ __ ] it
was all pretty mellow
he was pretty stealth yeah i was pretty
stealth about it
he had like a plain black yeah
i wasn't like i didn't have my i didn't
have the yeah dude logo on the side
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so great so i was pretty stealth i was
now the did you get the app on your
phone called
i overlander which is like gps and it
and
and it just marks spots where you can
get away with uh
with sleeping in your car overnight no
never got that everybody kept telling me
to get it and then people kept
i heard all kinds of apps and i was just
like most of the time i would just say
[ __ ] it and just go somewhere
and i kind of like figure out spots but
it was tough every morning trying to
find a place like i'd be like okay go to
a coffee shop
get a coffee and you know take a [ __ ]
there and then i'd kind of go from there
you know
then i'd like figure out my day i mean
dude like as a guy who's had
a van first had the little camper van
then i got this
you know big motor home which of course
for the people listening we're in it
right now this is with what i got
[Laughter]
okay so in any case um i had the camper
van and then i got this big motor home
for
like podcasting and stuff dude it is
it's an early move
to actually commit to living in the van
yeah
i would never i don't think want to do
that i
it you know what it did it humbled me i
totally got humbled from it
knowing that i could still survive with
a minimal amount of things
and still get to do what i wanted to do
like for the first
while i seriously was traveling and
hitting different skate parks
and i was loving that part of it the
only part i didn't
like was i thought i thought i could
handle like every day i'm waking up
film it do this it gets old trying to do
that when you're like
no i just want to show up and i just
want to skate so
that was work but it is very living in
it is very humbling
because you don't know what's right
outside of you and
you know you never know you know i one
of the best experiences i had
was i went to a campground in
sedona arizona up in the hills
and so i came from like sunny southern
california went up
and it was raining that night and they
said it was gonna snow
and so i had a little fire i was looking
up at the mountains i had a creek by me
and the next morning i woke up and i
opened the side door and it's just
snowing and i'm like this is the best
life i'm just sitting here having my cup
of coffee taking my [ __ ] taking a [ __ ]
taking the [ __ ] somewhere yeah dude
that's killer
do you miss it well he's got a van now
so you can
have it and my lady and i go all the
time we'll leave on
little van excursions just just for fun
she loves it too
yeah it's it's awesome i i won't get rid
of this van
i will always keep this van yeah just
because i like getting away
get ready this is going to be gnarly
pretty gnarly
kind of normal are we ready yeah
[Music]
what's up denver
women can paint their boobs and show
them on instagram
so i figure i should be able to paint my
dick and do whatever i want
make some noise for my brother
[Applause]
wait let me inspect for crabs this time
when my buddies lit that stuff right
away i knew
i [ __ ] up
i'm not doing this to hurt your dad
you're gonna hurt me you're gonna piss
me off